blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman so we've been following two
things with great interest number one is
um tuesday's gubernatorial election in
virginia very important race it's
democrat terry mcauliffe against
absolutely radical outrageous extremist
republican glenn younkin
and not only is that an important race
for virginia keeping virginia blue
but it also it's at least being
theorized is important maybe in terms of
how it would affect the politics of the
area including neighboring west virginia
and uh democratic senator joe manchin's
willingness to concede more or there's
all these different ways in which it's
important but it's a very important race
number two we've been following the new
i mean i think at this point it's a
trend
of republicans
saying
if we don't win
it's rigged if we don't win it's rigged
we saw this with the 2020 presidential
election
and we'll look at some other examples
republicans are already claiming fraud
in the virginia gubernatorial election
they're already doing it fraud exactly
they are now saying
it sounds like
we're hearing that democrats are already
cheating we're going to look at a video
now of the virginia republican state
senator amanda chase
she was interviewed on real america's
voice outside the beltway the day before
yesterday i believe it was
and she says uh democrats are cheating
they're already cheating folks they're
doing it every race now ahead of time
democrats are already cheating unless we
win
if we win we won despite the cheating if
we lose we lost because of the cheating
take a look look
um i'm all about fighting for the truth
too and and sometimes unfortunately we
can't always rely
on the media i wanted to go there i
wanted to feel it i wanted to see a
picture's worth a thousand words i know
how democrats are are cheating right and
that already we don't even have any
votes counted yet information has been
given to the yonkan campaign well
they're going to try to do it in fairfax
county absolutely you know
i'm already getting reports today
that people are going to vote and they
have never done a mail-in ballot ever
wow is that even legal yet when they
went to cast their ballot they were told
no we've already mailed you a mail-in
ballot and so we're already looking into
that that's okay so again those are
assertions about which there could be
multiple different explanations it is
not evidence of cheating it is not
evidence of fraud and it's not evidence
that it's democrats that are doing
anything that could even if true that
could be happening to the same number of
democrats and republicans it's three
layers of nonsense so that's why we told
everybody in virginia vote early so that
couldn't happen the earlier you voted
they couldn't do it
did you notice that now it's voters now
the right is saying vote as early as you
possibly can so this is the new thing
right before between the 2020
presidential and the california
gubernatorial recall we said this is
what they're going to do all the time
they did it with the california
gubernatorial recall remember when larry
elder the republican candidate was asked
the day before the election will you
commit to accepting the results and he
wouldn't we knew they were going to do
it there as well larry elder the leading
republican candidate would not commit to
accepting the results of the election
again whether or not you win or lose
will you accept the results of the
election tomorrow right i think we all
ought to be looking at election
integrity no matter whether you're a
democrat an independent or republican
let's all make sure that the election is
a fair election so let's all work
together no matter what the results are
to make sure that the results are are
valid and legitimate everybody who voted
should have voted let's all do that
together is that a commitment to accept
the results of the election tomorrow
let's all do that together let's all
work together uh on both sides of the
aisle to make sure that the election is
a fair election and so he didn't say he
would accept the results donald trump
did the exact same thing a few days
earlier before the california
gubernatorial recall on newsmax i think
this was on newsmax
saying it's all rigged it's all rigged
the democrats are cheating
well it's probably rigged they're
sending out all ballots it's all uh the
the ballots are you know mail out
mail-in ballots in fact i guess you even
have a case where you can make your own
ballot i made one on construction paper
with crayons when that happens uh
nobody's going to win except uh these
democrats so you know look they're very
good the one thing they're good at is
rigging elections so i predict it's a
rigged election let's see how it turns
out so that was ahead of the california
gubernatorial recall of course gavin
newsom won
by such insane numbers that it became
difficult to claim that it was actually
rigged
but they still did it so this is the
move now this is the move and the first
step
is terry mcauliffe has to win virginia
and tuesday night starting at 8 p.m
eastern maybe a little bit before i will
be doing live election results of what
is happening there as well as the new
jersey election we've got some mayoral
elections in different parts of the
country of consequence a lot of
different things
that's step one number two is really
thinking about the long-term impact of
this
that they are now using
if they didn't like the results or they
predict they might not win it's it was
rigged it was stolen etc not only
because of the systemic risk that it
presents in terms of just denouncing um
irrationally the basic institutions of
democracy in the united states but
it could lead to a sort of boy who cried
wolf situation where at a certain point
they actually rig an election and steal
it and when we point it out they can
come in and say guys we've been calling
out rigged elections for years and you
never paid attention until now because
you know they'll do it if given that
opportunity so concerning for a number
of reasons they're doing it in virginia
as well
this is interesting
um
the
former fox news host eric balling
now is a host on newsmax
he recently condemned fox news for
requiring vaccination or testing media
matters covered this and it's very
interesting because of eric balling's
history with fox news which we're going
to get to so let's actually just get
right to the clip uh here's eric's
balling eric balling
condemning the the vaccination policy of
his former employer but i i don't need
neil cavuto to tell me of what i should
be doing for vaccinations i can do that
for myself i'm back now we've covered
the neil cavuto thing if you don't know
what he's talking about neil cavuto is
like the lone voice on fox news saying
please get vaccinated please get
vaccinated cavuto got coveted despite
being vaccinated he's immunocompromised
he has multiple sclerosis he had heart
surgery etcetera okay so
eric balling is going after kabuto
i tell my my audience that i'm
vaccinated but i'm against the mandate
part of it fox says and neil cavuto says
you know we're against mandates too but
fox itself has a mandate you can't get
into 1200 sixth avenue unless you are
vaccinated or you're willing to take a
test every day and by the way true that
means all those cameramen all those
lighting people all those sound people
can't do their job so
it actually doesn't mean that it
actually means that everybody is safer
because they've either been vaccinated
or tested since it's just as onerous as
the vaccine mandate that de blasio has
but yet you won't hear that look
sean hannity is one of my closest
friends in the world and he calls it
straight that's a red flag tucker
sometimes has issues but but people like
cavuto was telling me that i should be
vaccinated and then turns around and and
says you know we're against vaccine
mandates yet his own company and neil's
an executive vice president of fox but
his own company demands that of the
other employees what gymnastics balling
is like i'm vaccinated and i'm for
vaccination and so is cavuto but cavuto
shouldn't be saying it on the air to
other people
not the neil cavutos of the world but
the producers the associate producers
the camera people there are a lot of
people who are bound by a vaccine man
that they're gonna have to take
otherwise they're gonna get likely fired
because they're not doing their job well
or you can get tested right he already
said and then the other issue of
this whole idea of were against the wall
culture they blasted major league
baseball for moving the all-star game
well that was until they held the
all-star game and fox
fox big fox
broadcast the all-star game i haven't
really heard them do it this time around
because guess where the world series is
being played it's being played half the
games are being played in atlanta well
i'm not hearing a lot of the pushback
from baby if you're thinking he sounds
like a disgruntled former employee you
may be on to something
broadcast on fox and i would like to see
where i would like that's my own player
but
and i just want to make this clear i'm
not taking unfair shots at fox i'm just
calling it like that like it is see i
would say the same thing about cnn and
msnbc but they clearly admit yeah so
listen i hate to make this about eric
balling personally but that word salad
made such little sense that i'm
wondering if he's just mad that fox news
got rid of him for these horrifying
allegations against him you can you can
see the whole story it's well documented
and sourced even just on wikipedia it
was reported that on a bunch of
occasions eric balling sent lewd text
messages and pictures to three female
colleagues at fox news and fox business
he made inappropriate comments to
employees uh the article this was
reported by huffington post and then a
former fox news guest caroline heldman
said
he made sexual advances against me that
were unwanted as well balling denied it
he was then suspended from fox news
pending an investigation a law firm was
brought in for the investigation
and then balling filed an intent to sue
over that
he never actually ended up suing over
the initial huffington post article
the huffington post stood by the article
ultimately
balling was ousted from fox news and the
report was that it was all amicable
but it is not clear that it was i hate
to make it a personal thing and that
this is just a grievance that eric
balling has against his former employer
but what he said doesn't really make any
sense it makes no sense at all
uh it actually makes perfect sense what
fox news is doing in order to reduce the
likelihood of people being out because
of covid it's bad for a business if
people have to call out sick it makes
sense to say you gotta be vaccinated or
test out they are going above and beyond
what joe biden recommended so very very
strange segment balling definitely seems
to have a major issue with his former
employer
i'd probably be disgruntled too but what
he's saying doesn't make any sense at
all let me know your thoughts you can
find me on twitter at d pacman hell of a
show for you today
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
remember that you can sign up in mere
moments at
joinpackman.com for a david pakman show
membership it comes with great perks
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
every day weekdays we take weekends off
uh the award-winning bonus show
priority on viewer town halls so many
different things sign up at
joinpakman.com let's hear from people in
the audience we are going to take some
calls via discord at davidpakman.com
discord last week brought us an almost
unblemished slate of calls both from a
content standpoint and an audio quality
standpoint and we're going to try to
keep that going this week let's go next
to eric from cancun eric you are on the
air
i'm sorry if i took the top colored
entitled because
that's how you call me last time we talk
and
and also
many of the viewers like the last time
we talked and i talked to my relatives
some friends about it
and here's what i'm thinking now
do you think would be better to deduct
taxes or charities because
then pain irs directly because
i do it because
um
to support these charities and because i
do care about them because i would not
totally trust the politicians with what
they do with their money in the money of
each one's country
eric let me see if i understand you're
saying instead of paying taxes to the
irs
just donate money to charities instead
um mostly because
these two
support the charities i do care about
and also because
i'd like some trust in the politicians
no i understand eric i don't need you to
i'm just asking is am i understanding
correctly what you said you're saying
instead of taxes to the irs donate to
charity
um mostly don't entirely only the dog to
charities but i do that because i will
not trust much in politicians no i
understand eric i don't need you to rep
i'm just i'm just trying to make sure i
understand so who pays for the roads if
instead of taxes we donate to charity
should pay some taxes to irs but mostly
to charities
okay all right eric thank you for the
call i very much appreciate it
uh let's go next to ryan from new york
ryan you're on the air
can you hear me yes i can
okay awesome thanks uh so i just had a
quick question uh regarding uh something
that was
said to me it's becoming american at
national and it's some i think it has
something to do with the sovereign
movement and i'm not sure if you had
already put up any content on this stuff
but i wanted to see if you had heard
about it and what your take was on that
wait a second so it's a movement called
american national
yes i think it's because uh
called like becoming an american
national you denounce your citizenship
from the united states oh
and it's part of the sovereign citizen
movement yeah i've i've heard about i've
i'm not familiar with this one in
particular i've heard about these before
if people want to see something really
entertaining
check out my interview a long time ago
with a guy named david windmiller who
believed that by adding elements of
punctuation to your name like extraneous
semicolons and dashes you became a
non-taxable sort of like sovereign
person and didn't owe any taxes to the
government
none of this stuff ever holds up legally
so i know that there's people who want
to do it but courts will still drag you
in and they'll still send you to jail i
mean it's it's it's a really wacky
movement um and unfortunately it's not
only benign because sometimes they get
violent
yes okay okay
uh
thank you for answering i'll definitely
check out that interview you're not
you're not thinking of becoming a
sovereign citizen are you ryan i am not
okay all right i don't think it's good
for anyone's career family life or
overall well-being
no yeah i was uh
like i just talked to some people and
that seems to be where their heads at
they say that uh
the united states we were unlawfully
converted into citizens right
uh all these different things so i i was
just kind of wondering because i don't
really subscribe to that mindset but i
sometimes don't really know what to say
to them so i'm just like okay
yeah i mean i guess often it's it's
a lot of the counterpoints are similar
to when libertarians just say taxes or
slavery and you never agreed to them
it's sort of like okay well so how did
you end up in this country and somebody
might say well i was born here
and then you would say okay so
so your parents decided to birth you in
this country right and they'd say yeah
uh it's like okay well
do you believe in parental custody until
kids are 18. and it's like if you do
then your parents decided for you they
opted you in by choosing to birth you in
the united states and then they might
say well
but my parents didn't choose to be
citizens of the united states and then
you just go up and eventually it's
someone who moved to the u.s so then
it's like okay so they knowingly came to
the united states knowing that they
would be subject to the laws here right
so they chose and then the next
generation chose to have a kid you know
it's it's so boring but it's like that's
the kind of way you've got to deal with
it
okay yeah yes thank you uh appreciate it
all right no problem there's ryan ryan
uh yeah that those movements will rot
your brain it's good to um be very very
careful
let's go next to uh oh how about magnus
from norway magnus you're on the air
can you hear me
just barely magnus so i'm going to pump
you up pump up your volume as much as i
can
um
wait let me try first
wow
barely audible
yeah wait a second here
uh
why is it so low
okay is it possible to try against a
little bit later
yeah you know if you speak up i've
pumped you up 200 so maybe we can hear
you if you have a question
um yeah i was just wondering um what do
you think about privatization of
electricity
privatization of electricity so are you
talking about the generation or the
distribution
um
i guess you can say both um
uh i i have no reason to think it's
something we should do why would we why
would we want to do it i guess um i know
like
the reason i'm i don't know if i'm pro
or anything but like um
i feel like it would
help reducing the price of electricity
in homes and stuff like
for instance in norway we have had some
increase in um the cost of uh
electricity yeah um
because so uh as my mother says she says
that it's because of
the
eu
that
we have to
increase the prices of like water for
instance
um
but i'm like
if we just privatize it wouldn't it like
decrease the prices it's not obvious to
me that it would you know in the i can
only speak to the united states but in
the united states electricity is is
quite regulated and different states
have different configurations but
one argument would be open competition
and then it will reduce the price
but the other side of it would be
actually
it it would actually increase the price
once you make it a for-profit model now
in some states where there's been
deregulation you can change your
electricity supplier you can shop around
but the complexity with electricity is
the delivery the delivery is still
happening by one company because
otherwise you need if you want to change
power company
you need different power lines and
that's very complicated to have each
company run its own power lines so if
you concede that the delivery needs to
be based on one infrastructure
you then start to kind of have a little
bit of a question mark around what gain
what benefit there really is to opening
it up uh in the in the way that you're
suggesting so i'm just not sure about
that
well uh thanks for answering at least
my pleasure magnus from norway thank you
so much for the call
let's go
next
to
benjamin
from seattle
hi can you hear me yes i can benjamin
so long time listener uh i actually have
to moderate watching you on youtube so
i'm not too much of a echo chamber good
uh because i agree with you a lot a
minor question uh with donald both
regarding donald trump
uh since he was commander-in-chief could
he be court-martialed regarding january
6 and would that be better legally
speaking i don't believe so i think you
know commander-in-chief refers to the
fact that
ultimately the president of the united
states is the commander-in-chief of the
u.s military but the president is a
civilian in charge of the u.s military
and i do not believe they would be
subject to a court martial
right my main question is did donald
trump really accomplish anything
uh in that i mean that
some of the things that are considered
part of his administration like
conservative supreme court justices is
really mitch mcconnell right uh big tax
cut uh paul ryan and then anything else
he did pretty incompetently
like the muslim ban was so badly done it
you know had to go to court several
times yeah so did he really accomplish
anything
except maybe just to stay out of the way
that well he didn't stay out of the way
trump accomplished many things that were
all negative he humiliated the world on
a global stage he set us behind on
climate he dr deborah burks earlier this
week said that trump's failure on covid
probably led to 30 to 40 percent more
deaths than we otherwise would have
needed so i think you're very much onto
something which is in terms of his
campaign promises trump did nothing he
did nothing but he damaged a lot of
things the absurd trade war with china
that did not benefit americans he did a
lot of things that were all bad but in
terms of what you would call political
accomplishments he barely did anything
and it's it's astute to point that out
so uh you mentioned the chinese trade
war would you say that some people
actually think that's a positive thing
though yeah i think there are some
people who think it is uh they they tend
not to understand what's going on when
you actually talk to them a little more
deeply though
okay well thank you very much my
pleasure thank you so much for the call
like getting right to the uh right right
to the big substantive
topics let's get to taylor from atlanta
georgia taylor you're on the air
hey david am i coming in okay you're
coming in okay yeah let's let's keep
going and see how it how it holds
okay
yeah sorry about i've got the
nod of uh bad call disapproval before so
let me try to fix this please uh but i
just wanted to get your thoughts on the
trends of childhood vaccinations in the
world
that's going on right now
i think we've walked back a little bit
based on the coveted vaccine and and
just general childhood vaccines
other than kovit and um
what you're thinking is going on i'm not
sure i know what you mean you're saying
are there just more vaccine hesitant
people when it comes to their kids
globally right now as a result of the
covet vaccine debate
yes yes i think childhood vaccines have
been pretty a pretty common thing and
not
giving a child vaccine has never been
questioned as hard as now yeah i'm
do is there any reason to think that the
covet vaccine debate is impacting other
vaccination i mean there have been these
anti-mmr
enclaves for a decade or more i've not
seen any evidence that suggests beyond
the debate about this vaccine that
there's a bigger anti-vaxx trend for
kids going on
yeah i mean there's been a slight
decline i think who has put out oh okay
a brief report on it um but that's been
going on since before covid okay i
didn't know usually these these metrics
um take a little bit of time like you
can't really look at 2021 just yet
i mean listen i think in the long term
it is going to remain clear that
vaccination has been one of the greatest
accomplishments of homo sapiens for
extending life and preventing death i i
think there you know we might have
there's a lot of anti-vaxx madness in
the u.s right now but i think that's the
long arc of vaccination
yeah great i i completely agree
um i personally have
you know i've i work in that realm i've
seen
i've personally seen children die from
these vaccine preventable diseases and
it's it's horrible so i just i hope that
that continues how you're saying you and
me both yeah i'm optimistic at will
cautiously optimistic
yes
all right thanks very much for the call
i appreciate it we're going to take a
very short break if you're holding don't
hang up because we are going to get
right back to the phones momentarily
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right let's take a few more calls
from great people in the audience you
can chat with me
um uh
well chat in a in a real sense in audio
visual or i guess just audio via discord
davidpakman.com
discord
let's go oh i don't know how about
daniel from alhamra
how are you david
i'm doing well can you hear me i can
hear you
all right a long time member first time
caller thank you um
just wanted to
point out um you know the colin powell
death you know it didn't take
republicans very long
uh to
you know kind of uh
get political with his death um you know
uh republicans tend to you know after a
mass shooting or something like that
you know they they tend not to want to
get too political about the issue
this is not a time to apologize
politicize tragedy they say
right you know and same with alec
baldwin the uh unfortunate situation
there
um i just thought it was kind of funny
that you know the republican uh the
right wingers uh didn't waste any time
politicizing yeah uh
um but
i have a question for you what would it
take what type of uh or what percentage
of audience
membership would it take to get david
pakman
to have uh like a person go out
uh to rallies
and do kind of like uh you're on the
spot coverage of some of these uh events
that's a beautiful question that's a
beautiful question i would love that um
i think that you know we talk about how
we estimate that somewhere between one
half and one percent of the total
audience
uh are paid members i think if we were
able to get to two percent we could hire
a full-time person to just go to these
wacky rallies protests and political
events
and do
really really good interviews and and
that type of thing that would be a
really exciting thing actually
yeah i would love it i mean i've been
watching or i've been a member since
your brother was on the show wow
his name yeah um so challenge accepted
audience if you're listening out there
let's get on board and get someone out
on the road to cover some of these
events
absolutely mr david here
thank you very much i appreciate the
call
all right thanks all right very good
yeah that's it i love that idea that's a
tremendous idea actually
um okay
why don't we let's talk to someone else
right i mean why not let's go to the
state of texas and talk to quincy from
texas quincy you're on there oh gosh
damn i didn't expect to get on okay
well anyways i was sort of curious um
you know i have a very difficult time
sort of empathizing with like the
viewpoints of conservatives okay it just
seems like
you know the more you take a more
empirical view on the world the more you
learn about history
you just can't sign off to a lot of
these things that like
conservatives worry about like they
worry about
you know like um like not changing race
policy even though we have like a
history of
basically oppressing races right like uh
i just
i just think that conservative is just
like um conservatism is just like dumb
overall
it just doesn't you're losing it sounds
like you're losing pace you're losing
patience for ignorance and stupidity it
sounds like
uh yeah i just um
i don't know i just feel like it's the
less
less intelligent position
and that like it's not really
set to like
stand the course of time really
well you know here's what i would say to
that without like arguing or debating
the merits of the because this is a very
it's a very surface level argument
conservatives are just dumb
let's skip the argument i think my
response to you would be hey you know
what
um just calling people dumb whether they
are or aren't probably isn't really
going to
achieve the change that we want and so
we need to think of what we can do like
let's say maybe that's true
or maybe they're not dumb but they're
just wrong or whatever right
either way we need to find some way
to
realize and deal with the fact that
these folks are a big part of american
society and we have some problems to
solve regardless and how can we actually
do it and it's not by just calling them
dumb so i think i would take like a more
pragmatic approach
okay i see what you mean
yeah are you clicking a pen or what is
that noise are you clicking a pen open
and shut uh it's uh it's a butterfly
knife you're opening and closing a knife
okay
yes all right good well listen i'm gonna
let you go let's continue to think about
this issue i think that there's a lot to
it and uh the only caller i'm aware of
that was doing knife play
during the phone call that we had let's
go
next
to
mike the new dad mike the new dad is on
the air
mike
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
how you doing man good congratulations
on being a new dad
thank you um i just wanted to say i
appreciate you kind of covering the pete
buda judge thing and
sort of trying to normalize uh paternity
leave for uh for new dads i kind of
thought it was a bit of a joke
being a new dad and actually being on it
i found it
quite beneficial since my wife kind of
wrapped up her maternity leave and i've
had this time to uh to bond with uh with
my daughter
are you do you get paid paternity leave
or you're just allowed to take time off
but unpaid
yeah no it's uh it's paid so uh if you
live in uh or work in the state of new
york um basically how it works is um the
state will cover 60 percent of your your
pay
um but a new policy like my company had
this year was is they just give you a
hundred percent of your pay and benefits
um while you're out on paternity leave
so it's a total of uh
12 weeks um so it works out to works out
to be three months and you just have to
use it within the first year of uh
of your of your child the date your
child's born so you could take it in two
week increments all at once however you
kind of want to split it up
but essentially
um
like my company actually i found out is
only
like even though they're giving me 100
of my pay they're only responsible for
40 the remaining 40 percent that was
going to be my question that was going
to be our question are they just
matching up to that last 40 yeah
yeah so they just match up to the last
40 so i mean
it it it's interesting that more
companies kind of don't do it like uh if
you work for a bigger business
considering they're they're only on the
hook for the the remaining 40 percent
and i mean i'm not an accountant but i'm
i'm sure there's some way that they're
going to be able to write off some of
that with with me not technically
working um but but yeah
and how much sleep are you getting
oh boy
you just cut out mike unfortunately it
sounded like you were trying to answer
but you just completely cut out
oh boy all right mike congratulations it
sounds like the the connection is
degenerating very very quickly uh so
we're gonna congratulations and i hope
that the answer to how much sleep you're
getting is a lot i hope it's a lot
let's go next to paul garcia from mexico
hi hello
um
i don't know i i guess i i just wanted
your thoughts on uh
a good book like good politics book
that take they teach me like
uh you know background from
conservatives and
you know new ground for progressives to
get into covered that's a great question
you know i i don't read any political
books so i'm like the worst person to
ask because i get so much politics in my
job i read history i read technology i
read do you have a narrative history
book like
friends revolution or something like
that french revolution no i really don't
know french revolution i've not i don't
know you know what i would do for all
these things if you just google
best book about the french revolution i
guarantee you you will find great
recommendations yeah i'd look at a few
cause
they say the french revolution start
kick start the whole revolution thing in
the world
uh
i just find it interesting i just wanted
to know uh
uh i
i'm just listening
that that was my only question
uh the chihuahua ah chihuahuan
well that's like 67 degrees that's not
that no 18 is like 66 or something isn't
it yeah yeah something like that that's
not bad that's not bad for almost
november
well
yeah that's that's the city chihuahua
but i live in a
uh a town apart okay it's like um 16
14 celsius okay got it how where did you
learn english
uh
my whole life i i i have taken english
from preschool
uh elementary
and middle school high school wow well
you speak excellent english my friend
well thank you i i really was fishing
for that
all right thanks paul great to hear from
you
yeah you too take care keep the good
work thank you there's paul garcia from
chihuahua in mexico love it
uh why don't we speak to
um
you know there's a lot of the phone
lines are packed today it's actually
crazy what's going on
um why don't we go to uh ryan from
newfoundland
ryan from newfoundland you're on the air
my friend
last chance ryan from newfoundland to
unmute yourself
all right that's too bad i was really
hoping to uh open to hear from that
let's try nicholas
from
switzerland one of my favorite countries
nicholas from switzerland
hey i'm uh glad you're doing fine
so can you hear me okay yes i can where
in switzerland are you calling from
i'm
calling from zurich oh i love zarya i
love zurich what a great secret
yeah it's it's great yes so
i've been watching uh your channel and
other us politics news for some years
now and what i've noticed is that
getting anything progressive to progress
is
almost impossible
i feel like
uh any
anything good
is almost impossible to get through into
legislation and it feels like we're
always talking about the same things and
it's like can we get them done or if
we're we're clearly getting nothing done
if we keep asking for the same things
right
yes exactly
and so what i was wondering i
uh recently i went to a job interview
and
they asked me uh where do i see myself
in like 20 years okay and
i
thought about it and
i thought it was really hard but i
wanted to ask you
where
do you see the us in 20 years you know
in terms of progressive policies and
social changes i think that number one
things change so quickly and number two
humans are terrible at predicting things
that i don't even waste time thinking
about something like that it's sort of
like when people say where do you
imagine your show will be in five years
i say i have no idea i have a plan for
this year and i have a plan for next
year and five years ago if anyone and
people did say
where do you see the show in five years
nothing i imagined is actually what's
going on right now so here's what i
would say
even though we're generally always
talking about the same things we've got
to raise the minimum wage we've got to
provide health care we've got to reduce
income inequality we've got to deal with
the environment when you look year by
year or over a few years things are
happening the minimum wage is going up
although too slowly
more people have health care today than
having a long time although not nearly
enough and it's not affordable enough
we are getting closer to getting off of
gasoline-powered vehicles and closer to
electric so i think it's very easy to
get really bummed out because we aren't
going quickly enough i agree
but
there is also progress being made 20
years it's too long to make any
reasonable prediction
it would be of no value for me to
predict
okay and do you think like
uh over time
congress will get more or less
functional
that's a really good question i i worry
it will not get more functional let's
put it that way it might not be less
functional but i'm worried it's not
going to get any more functional anytime
soon
that's a prediction i'm willing to make
okay great yeah yeah that's about it
thanks for having me how's the weather
in zurich these days
uh
it's it's getting cold really but uh
it's it's nice yeah we have clear skies
all day
and yeah except except for the
temperature it's uh
perfect how cold does it get in winter
in zurich like in january
oh it really depends on the year but uh
not that cool like in the morning it
would get like minus minus seven maybe
okay minus seven celsius
celsius yeah yeah we don't do imperial
here and how much snow do you guys get
oh that also really depends i mean
luckily in switzerland you can always go
to like garbunden or vallis
and go into the mountain
mountains and go skiing there there's
all almost uh
snow
all year there
and during the winter for sure but here
in zurich
it's it really depends on the year
sometimes we
never get snow sometimes we get snow
like all year right but if it can go
from like five centimeters up to like 30
was i think the back side we ever had
here for the entire season or per storm
uh no no it's it's
there there would be like one big
snow storm and it would snow for a
couple of days and there would be like
10 centimeters for maybe
a month got it got it got it well it's a
fan do you like living in switzerland
i've enjoyed my time there so much
yeah i mean it's it's really great here
i mean standard standard of living is
like outstanding of course
and we have
yeah school has been great for me i've
i've
enjoyed so many opportunities to do
whatever i wanted to do
yeah i really like it here fantastic
well congratulations on living in
switzerland and i really appreciate the
call
thank you very much all right very good
there is nicholas from switzerland all
right that's all the time i have for
today we'll take a break we'll get to
your emails momentarily and we will take
live calls again very soon before you
know it we'll be speaking again
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow all right
let's get into this week's mailbag you
can email info at davidpakman.com to
participate please don't abuse that
email address we'll just block it we
have many people whose emails are
filtered directly into the trash because
they email us too much or into a folder
we keep in case law enforcement ever
asks for emails from people yeah it does
happen it does happen maybe stories to
tell someday about that uh no but in all
seriousness don't abuse it okay info
davidpakman.com let's jump right into
our first email first email
is from alexander
who says i'll just get to the point
you are a loser and always will be lost
in space sleepy joe biden and his
administration opened the eyes of so
many that voted for him by all of his
screw-ups since taking office and now
realize what a stupid mistake it was to
have believed the lies of his campaign
message
2024 is just around the corner and once
again america will be great again under
the leadership of president donald trump
i disagree with the characterization of
what trump's leadership would be
but i don't for a second take issue
with the very real possibility that
donald trump will be president again
this country is dumb enough to do it
again they were dumb enough to do it
once when it was obvious it would be a
disaster and it was
and they are clearly
eager to do it again so it's going to
come down as it often does to turn out
there will be no matter what trump does
between now and 2024 other than maybe
die and even then they might still put
him on the ballot and vote for him no
matter what trump does between now and
2024
there will be tens
of millions of people
just like the guy who emailed me
who will gleefully vote for another four
years of that insanity so we need to be
prepared i disagree it'll be great
but the emailer is absolutely right you
very well could see trump again in 2024
and that's a very scary scary thing
um here's another
very aggressive message
it's i'm gonna read it as written
okay and uh yeah
well well gay jews boy
ever thought that the man you hate so
much as the peacemaker in the middle
east ye trump know you are so full of
hate and beside that so stupid not to
see what his what this dementia joe
biden is doing to the usa never a single
word from you about the laptop full of
sex with underage girls the money scam
for the big man
from the ukraine flying the air force
won
the can the private deal made the biden
family is the most big crime family ever
in the white house
then he cannot speak one good word after
the other one great disaster so tell me
boy how on earth can you not speak
sorry how on earth can you put up
with this and saying nothing about it
just get the news from more good
democrats friends that wall mark closed
22 stores
in the left-wing california
why because people can riot and lotting
the stores and would not get arrested
yes under biden this will harm the whole
usa but you keep silent about this gas
prices up food 2 dollar down yes gay boy
that's where you voted for
but because you can no better will not
talk about this but hang out with the
trump old story happy day boy all the
best we know you need it fritz the with
yeah
next email okay
austin wrote to me about republican
hypocrisy on comorbidities david i saw
your recent segment on tucker reporting
on colin powell's death i found it very
interesting that for the duration of the
pandemic republicans were constantly
talking about how coveted deaths are
overstated and many people are dying
from other causes for some reason that
all seemed to go right out the window
when colin powell died now it's
certainly a coveted death
implying powell wasn't already immune
immunocompromised and had apparently
nothing to do with the other ailments he
was suffering from
of course as you stated
uh this is just has everything to do
with undermining the vaccine yeah it is
funny where before any time anybody died
of covid supposedly it was like no no no
no they didn't really die of covid they
were killed by doctors at hospitals we
covered that one
they died from a car accident but then
they were just tested for covid and
because they had it it counts as a cove
death
they were marked as a cove of death so
the hospital could make more money etc
now colin powell dies of co oh
look at that it's absolutely coveted
yeah the the skepticism again this is
because none of these are their values
or their actual underlying beliefs it's
just
what can we say today
to make the point we're already
determined to make
that's that's quite simply what it is
and it's a very good point nobody's
saying hey you know what we've been
saying for a year and a half when
someone supposedly dies of covid we
should be skeptical with colin powell
nobody's skeptical now he yep he died of
covet no question whatsoever
biden's christmas
paul wrote to me saying david sir does
it not seem odd that the people most
worried that christmas will be ruined by
supply chain issues are essentially
admitting not only that christmas is not
primarily a celebration of the birth of
christ but that it is also a custom
built upon the giving of chinese-made
goods i am not religious but what
happened to christ is the reason for the
season what happened to buy american
right-wing audiences can be convinced of
the exact opposite of what they espouse
very bizarre stuff yeah paul's this is
sort of like another example of you've
got their stated principles and then
you've got their actions
when the principles no longer correspond
with the point they want to make
there's an attack on christianity and
it's all about jesus and religiosity and
we should buy american because we're
republicans
uh oh we're having problems with chinese
supply chains
that's going to ruin christmas no
mention of jesus no mention of by
american just it's joe biden's fault
that we're not going to be able to get
our chinese toys
same analysis as before that you know
none of the things they i don't know
that they believe any of the things they
say
they'll use them to make political
points if it's so convenient and that's
about as far as it goes
really good message about the dennis
prager thing we talked last week about
how dennis prager tested positive for
covid and he's taking five medications
and he said he wanted to test positive
for it joe from virginia wrote in and
said hey david do people like dennis
prager not see the irony in wanting to
catch covid in order to develop natural
immunity they want to catch the virus
in order to develop antibodies
so that they're less likely to catch it
again in the future it makes no sense
why not just never catch it in the first
place it's like if i told you i could
hit you with a car today and in exchange
your chance of being hit by a car in the
future will be reduced reasonable people
would decline being hit with the car at
all getting vaccinated in this scenario
prager's logic if it can even be called
logic makes it seem like he'd take on
the car yeah this is something we've
been talking about for a while
we want to get covid get everybody sick
so that then you're protected in the
future
right but millions of people would die
with the herd immunity approach why not
just avoid catching it if only there was
something that could reduce our chance
of catching it and of course that
something
is the vaccine that they just make no
sense um
there was
a time
and
maybe
it
to some degree still applies although i
don't know enough about it before there
was any any you know chickenpox vaccine
there would be the idea of you get your
kids together so that they pass
chickenpox and you get get it out of the
way because getting chickenpox as an
adolescent or an adult or shingles it
can be really really really bad
so that's something that used to go on
like when my parents were kids even when
i was a kid it was already not being
done that that i'm aware of
uh but what dennis prager saying it's
like i want to get the virus to have a
lower chance of getting it in the future
well why not just get the vaccine and
reduce your chance of getting it at all
and try to avoid it it seems more
logical partic by the way particularly
when remember vincent racaniello one of
the top virologists in the u.s from
columbia university we interviewed him
and he said
it would be expected
generally speaking the trajectory over
time would be that the the coronavirus
the kovat 19 sars kovi 2 gets less
serious over time
so
there's really
not an advantage to getting it now
uh very very strange stuff but you know
none of what they're doing makes sense
riley wrote to me about a teacher
wearing a star of david in protest of
the vaccine saying hey david i thought
this might catch your interest a
berendos middle school teacher in red
bluff california posted this video
comparing the holocaust to the vaccine
mandate just to add to the cringe she
cut out a star of david and asks
followers to pin them on their shirts as
part of her protest she took down the
original poster to the outrage and
reposted the same message this time with
a blue star yeah i saw the original
video with the yellow star and then i
saw a subsequent video where the same
teacher then did a video with a blue
star because apparently the yellow star
a lot of people said you're trivializing
the holocaust again like so many of
these anti-vaxxers have done in fact
last week i told you about a report that
looked at coveted conspiracies
pushing people either overtly or sort of
in a more below the radar way towards
anti-semitism trivialization of the
holocaust through false equivalencies
between concentration camps and vaccine
requirements by employers um and schools
were that was listed as one of those
things and i did see the video i'm not
going to play it um but you can
certainly find it if you are interested
liz wrote to me about a weird new
republican conspiracy
liz says hey david i've been hearing an
argument being made by some of my
right-wing friends that i'm having
trouble connecting with any factual
reference point shocker i know but i try
to understand what frightens the right
and i can't figure out where this one
came from they seem convinced lately
that the government is monitoring any
transactions over six hundred dollars in
our private bank accounts
where is this talking point coming from
is it true i have not heard anything
about this so i don't even know how to
remotely deal with this as an argument
against supposed government overreach so
here's my suspicion about where that
comes from
there was one point at which the false
rumor was being spread
that the six hundred dollar stimulus
from i believe the trump era the six
hundred dollar coveted stimulus was it
six hundred
that it was going to be
taxed as income so you get money from
the government then you pay taxes on it
now it wasn't true
if you got 600 from the government you
were supposed to report it on your taxes
and then in a separate part you're asked
did you get coveted stimulus you put yes
and you put in the amount and you get a
credit so it offsets it's just reporting
right it doesn't change your taxable
income i say uh on the one hand here's
600 i received on the other hand here's
a credit uh that six hundred dollars is
deductible it zeros out okay
i wonder
if the government is monitoring
transactions over six hundred dollars is
somehow related to
the previous false rumor that the
coveted stimulus money would be taxable
i don't know and this is a funny thing
every day there's a new one of these
and sometimes we know where it comes
from sometimes we don't sometimes
hilariously or tragically
these come from just misunderstanding
some other false conspiracy delusion
um so i don't know but my suspicion is
it has something to do with the false
claim that the covet stimulus money was
going to be taxed also uh lastly today
from the mailbag andrew wrote to me
about hypocrisy
and says hey david just want to point
out the hypocrisy here for a party so
consumed by statistics and how the one
percent that got die from covid isn't a
big deal
why are they so concerned about 10 000
haitians coming to texas which is only
about 3.5 percent of texas's 29 million
well and not only that only a fraction
of them would actually stay in texas
which is another issue yeah listen
andrew it's not none of it's logical
none of it's logical you can try to
present uh you can try to present
empirical data to these folks it doesn't
make a difference if they've decided
it's an invasion of haitian migrants uh
as trump said who have aids as other
republicans have said who will
you know suck the country dry of
resources whatever if they've convinced
themselves of that
no data that you present is going to
change their minds that's fundamentally
what it comes down to
and uh it's at this point it shouldn't
come as a big shock we've got a great
bonus show planned for you today there's
another show every day we do the one
hour broadcast show podcast that's this
that you're listening to watching right
now excuse me
and then we do an additional bonus show
just for our members you can sign up at
joinpakman.com
use the coupon code
felony21 it's such a big discount it
should be a felony i think actually ted
cruz wants to make it one but we're
pushing against that big discount felony
21
join pacman.com see you on the bonus
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman